so what are you doing these days so I've
discovered beyond just my own strength
of killings yoni eggs yoni hey yes okay
didn't never heard of yoni eggs so the
idea is yoni means womb and this is
where life starts so this is a pretty
pretty important areas you know it's
it's the life-giving force earth so yoni
eggs are our stones they can be Jade
they can be rose quartz they can be any
kind of crystal you want to get your egg
your yoni egg which is in the shape of
an egg and because you want to wear this
ladies you want to put it right up in
there this is a stone I brought I know I
took they put something out here I have
one in wait wait you wanna I wait a
minute I mean I haven't one knees but
there's your you have one now right now
wait a minute how did you get past
security
hey so you have within you in the
life-force area yeah and you know in
your intimate situations ladies you can
keep them in now you want to be careful
because like what wait a minute listen
this is a legitimate thing if I'm doing
my thing and suddenly there's knocks up
in there
seriously you know the mean if I'm doing
my lips
hey you're not afraid of a rock you can
handle that split that lock
[Applause]
this is heavy you want to work your way
down wait you mean you work your way up
no you want to start there and then you
start with this yeah you want to end up
here okay there's a middle one you put
it in see you some people need a string
to pull it out now like let's don't make
me see sneeze because they can shoot out
yeah we should have put chicken wire
over the other
Marcus yeah maybe's yeah some buckets
with you have scored so so these are
okay your yoni stone yeah and you so you
wanna you want oh you want to put clean
them in hot water and then put them in
the Sun to charge for eight hours so you
can get the properties of the stone yeah
I got the rose quartz right here now for
love sending it out bringing it in and
you put your stone in have anyone ever
microwaved it first or just if we don't
have eight hours you know you just put
it in there and then no and then you
know if you sleep with it under your
pillow for a couple nights and just put
some pretty intentions in there and then
just it goes right in you want to you
you want to put the pointy the rounder
side in first okay
sure it's not QVC I mean we don't know
it order yours now you know we don't
need the hole so these are obviously
just for women these are just you know
well well where could yours go I don't
know
mine would know I'm mine no I would go
nowhere to be fair I'm wearing one right
now
oh my god that's what I want to know
it's kind of a composite ran it yes yeah
yeah yeah
it's rather it's larger than any of
these
you